guillen maxwell was the socialite whose
manners and magnetism attracted princes
and presidents but it was those same
qualities she used to ensnare girls from
troubled backgrounds teenagers whom she
served up for abuse by jeffrey epstein
her siblings were in court as the
verdict was read out they know she'll
almost certainly spend the rest of her
life in prison so too do her lawyers
laura i wonder if you can reflect on why
you think
that this jury believed the
prosecution's case that glenn maxwell
was a sexual predator
it was the verdict her accusers say is
long overdue
among them sarah ransom who was in court
for some of the trial what was it that
gillane did
to
manipulate girls in order to serve them
up to jeffrey epstein what was her role
in the crime so guillen was the main
enforcer she was um you know even before
i met elaine
jeffrey said you answer to gilean you
know
she is the lady of the house she is
um you just don't cross her she forced
me into jeffrey's room to be raped
and then when i walked out
well walked limped i mean whatever you
do when you've just been been brutally
raped
i looked at her
and that's why it was really important
for me to be there
and look at her because when i looked at
her
after she forced me into the room to be
raped
she smiled
and that's why i had to be there because
you know what
i smiled right back right back at her
and i saw her
four survivors took the stand in this
case they were girls when they were
abused they're now grown women who
stepped out of the shadows and into this
court to tell their story and ultimately
it was that testimony which brought down
gulen maxwell
but after the verdict her family and
friends remained defiant
we firmly believe in glenn's innocence
obviously we are very disappointed with
the verdict we have already started
working on the appeal and we are
confident that she will be vindicated
your excellencies presidents lords
ladies and gentlemen maxwell once used
her platform to address the un she
traveled the world in a way only the
super wealthy ever will but her
privilege in the end was no protection
for the crimes she committed martha
kellner sky news new york